thank you Lord for giving me this faith
a girl I can't with you now
[Music]
right for me
I removed the cat eyes BB I like the BB
Kuzma that's kind of my initials busty
brown they used to call me back in the
day
and then I didn't warn the face of this
warm it warm it up then I just got to
figure out what that I'm scared this is
a very interesting this is actually
funny no I know that's what I'm saying
that's been used I purchased my Beauty
Blender from the dollar store
yes I do
oh my gosh cuz I mean I just can't be
seen paying a forty fifty dollars for
pieces fine that's a lot just gonna
cover my beard even is gonna do you
really think that I'll look like I came
from the mat counter I think you look
like a counter tell me why I actually
love his eyebrows oh oh you know [ __ ]
sticky is frack but your eye looks good
I ain't seen out like that on you
compliment because I'm mad this is
dollar store makeup and it looks she
looks good
I do though I'm into it very
[Music]
done nothing right if I go add that
right and there
[Music]
what budget
[Music]